[Music]
and burnt bacon news my favorite yeah
you like it crispy apart I [ __ ] love
that [ __ ] crispy I always tell people at
Denny's like I want you to bring my baby
or speak until you feel bad about
serving it's for real like black black
almost black almost Oh like I wanted
[ __ ] crunchy I want to crumble in my
face all right
submitted by a Tongan girl who loves Joe
hey hey Dawkins island beat bow
firefighters who saved piglets from a
barn fire get sausage made from those
pigs in return as a thank you who the
[ __ ] what a slap in the face I feel like
these are American firefighters in China
yeah I saved you just to kill you and
eat you what back to slap who made the
sausage but are they the farms or the
firefighters yet did they save a farm
yeah so the firefighters they went to
this fire where all these haystacks were
caught on fire and they saved 18 piglets
from this box oh you and they killed the
mothers and turn them into sausages then
this farm they said you know once
they're ready we're gonna we're gonna
stop by the firehouse and say thank you
and give you some bangers cuz this is in
the UK so while they're eating it
there's like I'm so glad they do you're
delicious that's weird that's [ __ ]
weird
they had like a smoky flavor to them the
pig oh yeah and then the firehouse
saying that are posting this on their
Facebook would you like 200 exactly six
months and one day since ffs ffs' old
writers since firefighters Olson and
Richardson rescued 18 piglets from a
farm in Milton and now we have 18
sausages we got to sample the fruits of
our labor from that February night huge
thank you to Rachael rivers for dropping
them off for us to sample highly
recommend but are recommended by Pusey
fire stations crew and if any one of our
followers is having a bank holiday
barbecue this weekend then check out
these sausages they are fantastic that's
pretty funny this is really weird but
okay okay I thought okay
I feel I feel a little bit better
because I thought they literally killed
them right after they rescued them no
they waited six non evading yeah so they
were like full-grown and yeah cuz I'm
sucking they're like oh thanks and toss
it in the [ __ ] grinder
you know the farmer was the one that
went back and so what's what's the big
deal so once we posted that on their
Facebook page they immediately got you
know Peter yes okay crazy yeah so
apparently there were people commenting
like Hulk could you
if you rescue puppies would you still
eat them and like they just twisted it
that doesn't even make sense I rescued
the dogs from the dog shelter that was
burning down and then I turned him into
dog steak no that's not even what
they're for originally meant for that
exactly that's like that's like I saved
the [ __ ] rice field from burning down
and then I get a bag of rice later yeah
how dare you I think it's a little bit
different because yes they're being
sensitive but it's like if you went to
the extent of saving these humans that
mean these humans these animals lives
these animals lives then they obviously
mean more than just food if you're gonna
risk human life to save these animals
lives right so it's just ironic now that
you risked again the human life to save
this this livestock that now you're
eating it six months is odd then more
it's ironic
yeah but if you really boil it down it's
just firefighters doing their job and
then this business because their
business got saved they're giving them
free product yeah I get I get it but
from a sensitive standpoint I get them
too yeah yeah the sensitive part is what
makes it ironic do you have specific
comments that people say I know I don't
have because they deleted the post so I
was only able to read a few but yeah
like that that make the internet so
boring and goodbye delete posts and
those guys even taste the sausages so
how do they know if it was probably
[ __ ] bomb after a bomb you know I
love sausage right I always get my the
breakfast sausage
you want your sausage burners [ __ ] - no
no just make like juicy sausages we need
to fight it - impossible inside I
thought juicy oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
that's so good
you see what the farmer say so yeah so
the farmer was just saying that she
wanted to thank the firefighters and
that they can't keep these pigs as pets
because they farm and that's just what
they do know that for food food
livelihood yeah get different day job
I'm speaking for my sensitive person I
don't know I'm trying to get into the
minds of people that are upset are they
non-meat eaters or are they vegans
probably not so it's all vegans getting
angry vegetarian vegetarian I wouldn't
even put it just on that I think it
should literally just sensitive people
yeah
sensitive people as in like people I
don't know it's just I'm wondering where
these people are coming from because I
don't think there's that many vegans in
the world
no but there's a lot of [ __ ] dumb
answers yes that don't connect like this
is food yeah they're supposed to [ __ ]
do this [ __ ] yo gets a lot of hate on
this channel for no for having your love
towards animals and then people were I
get a lot of hate really yeah there's a
lot of people are saying like oh you're
a hypocrite cuz you still eat meat all
over yeah I mean that's something that I
I dunno but um yeah I mean I don't give
a [ __ ] like I'm not gonna like go in
like slaughter [ __ ] or whatever I'm not
gonna abuse and whatever like I'm
probably doing more than a lot of you
people out there anyway so okay yeah
it's a mentality of people the same and
tell you that people attack you for
they're attacking this fire station like
how could you eat them if you saved them
and like if and then they compare them
to other animals to like oh they're like
free animals that humans see them like
that we didn't even furry I didn't want
people of the people that are sensitive
they're twisting it because they're
viewing the pigs as pets or using them
as like a human being when these pigs
are meant to be product and food so it's
literally like what Joe is saying like
if you if you go and save this cornfield
and then the farmers so happy that they
save the cornfield
they bring you tortillas or they bring
you live just so happy that they're and
they're pink and they're cute but
they're meant for food they're meant for
consumption yeah so because you saved my
farm now I'm giving you what I farmed I
think a lot of people will get sensitive
about things are you simply cute
I mean but they're not really sensitive
because then they're still consuming it
yeah like it's uh it's like when I used
to feed my snake rats are like how dare
you how could you it's like Oh for the
rat yeah my snake has to eat just
because one thing is cuter and fluffier
than the other has a venom it's that's
the thing I always had about like animal
rights people yeah is they pick and
choose based off how cute something yeah
so they won't fight for [ __ ] worms
but they fight so hard for bunny rabbits
and it's like that doesn't make any
sense because you're discriminating I
still you meet um but I'm not killing
[ __ ] I do kill mosquitoes that's
funny I'm not killing every animal hater
how [ __ ] doing that yeah that's true
spiders because because earlier Gina
found a spider one of our fridges and
then - you're just saying don't kill
don't kill don't kill it just take it
out I think it's it's difficult for
people to follow that logic because it's
like how can you eat meat but at the
same time appear as though you're
against the consumption of me it's hard
to I mean you do I I definitely have my
moments when I actually think about it
when I'm like there and I'm aware and
I'm in the moment and I'm conscious
about it it's hard or maybe people can't
understand that thought process process
because it's conflicting it's easier to
digest when someone goes I'm a vegan so
I don't like yeah animal [ __ ] yeah but
in if you consume meat products and at
the same time you don't you're you're
you're you're against what appears like
animal cruel I mean just killing of
animals in general so like how there are
people like that out there how do you
differentiate or how do you like explain
that I mean I think it's hard because
you're trying to fight a battle with
someone that's already very
closed-minded
or it just doesn't want to wrap their
head around it not mean for you like so
so people can understand you better so
like you know how they expect like you
if you're if you're for animal rights
and all this stuff right yeah then they
expect you to be vegan or at least
vegetarian or but what if it's like I
it's not that I am see see I eat meat
but I'm against killing them in inhumane
ways I have a friend like that yeah I
mean it's still hard like I don't know
if that can't even be explained so
simply you know what I mean like I know
that I was vegetarian for several years
and that was like something that was
hard for me to sustain financially and
just cuz I didn't know enough at that
time um and now just with my life like
it's it's something hard that's really
to it that's just kind of hard to
explain I don't know like I'm even
conflicted with myself you don't have to
hate animals to eat meat and they look
the other way around like I don't hate
animals I love animals yeah if we can do
commercial farming in a more yeah like
you know like find a way to let them
live uh you know a fulfilling life not
like full of abuse and all that and then
boom just kill them as efficiently as
possible yeah and as humans we take out
consume meat consumption just one day
out of the week and the production of it
will go down and then the animals we
don't have to farm so many animals they
don't have to be living in such
congested environment if we would
consume a little less and another thing
too is we're so disconnected with that's
me watching our food being killed and
like kill like like back in a day a lot
of people killed what they ate hmm aside
from fish and other things like I don't
know what it feels like to kill a man
will kill a bird and then cleaning it
and going through the process of the
work and I think from there it's like I
probably appreciate my meat way more if
I did that but now that so many people
are like you you get a package of a
piece of animal and then you consume
that and you don't connect that this
cute little bird that's walking around
at this
State Fair is my fried chicken or
whatever actually actively think about
that a lot we finish my food really I'll
be like oh you didn't die for no reason
buddy I got to eat you like I do you
think of the chicken going I was like I
can't let you die in vain like I have to
eat you I guess I think that's actually
more responsible though I feel like one
of the most responsible places is
actually Chinese restaurants they use
everything you go oh look at that cute
little Lobster I want that one take that
one and so you have a direct connection
with what you're eating versus like a
lot of the TV shows like people they
just they already start with this
perfectly cut stick and today I'm going
to put rosemary whatever but they're
skipping half of the process yeah you
need the full fish you need to chop off
that [ __ ] head cut it up yeah
scale it and then you need to cut it out
and then BOOM yeah well then you start
realizing that this animal is like I'm
eating this thing yeah they need a show
like Gordon Ramsay going to like a
grass-fed beef place and they go I want
this with a shaved off [ __ ] out of the
cow take a big cut the pieces off and
then it'd be way more responsible cuz
it's almost like you you show a car to
just show it being made from like it's
already half done but you got to see the
mining of the metal what does it do that
an environment all that stuff because my
aunt grew up on a farm and she said that
they didn't eat that much meat back in a
day because of the labor that it took
and they had to do it themselves so
because of all the like you know if you
want a chicken you have to kill the
chicken pluck it do all that stuff so it
was like the meat consumption was a lot
less than what it is today it's so much
easier not just pay some money and like
boom I get my shabu I get my steak I get
whatever I want and I don't feel bad
when I throw away like if I'm falling
I'm like huh that's it but I'm pretty
sure if I had to do all that work then
I'd probably think about it hey you guys
want to stock any of us we'll go ahead
down to the description box below
and you can follow us on Instagram and
all kinds of stuff for more videos
[Music]